Speaker 1: All right, let's hear from a few more
people in The David Pakman Show audience. We take
calls via discord. You can find that at David
Pakman dot com slash discord. Why don't we go
first in this segment to Meg
B, Meg B, you are on the air.
Speaker 5: High in the army. Yes, I can. Oh,
my gosh, I can't believe I'm talking to you.
Speaker 1: I can't believe
I'm talking to you, Meg.
Speaker 5: Oh, my gosh. OK, my husband's going
to freak. OK, so I really have a big question
about the march for Medicare for all, because I
don't know that I saw it on the Humanists report,
and so I got excited about it. And then all
of a sudden I looked it up more. And there
are all these controversies about neo-Nazis
organizing it and gathering information. So
I keep on trying to get more information on it and
no one is giving us information. And so my husband
reserved a hotel in Austin. And so then he's
like, are we going to go to it or what? I said,
I don't know because I can't get more
information. I'm really nervous because I
trust the humanists report, but I don't really
see anyone else covering it. So I can tell you
Speaker 1: I don't know a thing about this
is a Texas march for Medicare for all.
Speaker 5: Well, no, it's a it's national and
it's in I think it's like in 30 different states
or something like that, and that's when
Speaker 1: is it taking place
Speaker 5: on June 24th, which is supposed
to be the birthday of Medicare, but
Speaker 1: that June of twenty twenty two.
Speaker 5: Now, June, I mean,
not June. I'm sorry, July. Twenty Fourth.
Speaker 1: Oh, I just don't know anything
about it. You know, with all of it I don't really
go anywhere and I'm trying to avoid big crowds. So
I couldn't I really couldn't tell you anything
about it. It strikes me as implausible that
neo-Nazis are organizing it. But it's certainly
it's certainly plausible that neo-Nazis are
infiltrating it. I really don't know a thing about
it. I couldn't I wouldn't say. But I you know,
what I appreciate is that you're even asking
these questions because a lot of people end up
at events they don't even understand. So I
like that you're you're investigating this.
Speaker 5: OK, well, I really appreciate it. I've
been watching you for years and years and years,
so thank you so much for taking my call.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. I'm glad to have
spoken to you today. Thanks. All right. Say hi
to your husband for me. Beautiful. OK, perfect
phone call. Really perfect phone call. A beautiful
call, the likes of which we've only read about,
why don't we go next to I'm hope, I hope, I
pronounce it correctly, is it Kumah from China?
Yep, can't get me out of it. I can hear you fine.
Speaker 6: OK, thank you. So I'm a Chinese
immigrant who currently lives in Canada. Oh, I
don't I still don't. I still don't speak English,
so please bear with me. No, you're
Speaker 1: great. So you're doing great.
Speaker 6: So the other day I read this quote
from Roger Scootin. It goes, something like,
Conservatisms starts from the sentiment
that good things are easily destroyed but
not easily created. So my mom is a very
interesting case when I think about this.
She's against everything that has been going on in
China for the last few decades. Mm hmm. Her family
were victims of the Cultural Revolution. Yes. She
wants more democracy, human rights protection,
you know, checks and balances for the government.
So I guess in that in that sense, she is a
progressive. But when it comes to U.S. politics,
she's a huge Trump supporter. And just because
Trump is very hard on China and I guess she's
just a bit, you know, traumatized by socialist
ideologies because the Chinese government has
never really put it off and has done a lot of
bad things under the name of socialism. So she
would be a conservative if she were in the U.S.
today. And I can speak the same for most of
Chinese immigrants of her age and view in the
U.S. interests. My. Yes, so my question is, how
much conservatism in the U.S. do you think comes
from the sentiment that things are generally good
and we should not rush to change it versus the
actual policies or ideas like in my mom's case?
Speaker 1: So I think there's there's actually
there are numerous immigrant populations that
are that tend to be conservative or at least
are frequently conservative. One is, as you're
talking about, Chinese immigrants of a certain age
who are really only conservative in in one sense,
as you're pointing out, but at the same time
sort of have what we might consider more of a
leftist critique against the Chinese regime of the
Cultural Revolution. That's one group. We've also
talked about certain Latin American immigrants,
in particular Cuban-Americans, some
Venezuelans, and then also there are
some centrist South and Latin Americans who just
kind of end up voting for moderate Republicans
because they see them as sort of like as you're
pointing out. Exactly. They're like things are
better in the US than they were where I came from.
And it feels like those moderate Republicans are
sort of trying to keep things in that way. They're
not on board with, like, the radical right stuff,
but they're just like I'm kind of a moderate
conservative. And then you also have another
group is there's a surprisingly high number of
Eastern Europeans, including Russians and others,
who tend to surprise me often when they when
I learn that they are actually pro Trump. And
I think that there's a couple different things.
One aspect is they see American Republicanism
as the opposite of what they abandoned in their
country, rightly or wrongly, and therefore they
just sort of gravitate towards it. That's one
piece of it. The other piece of it is exactly
what you're saying, which is the idea that if
you think things are sort of pretty good, then
sometimes you say, well, let's keep things the way
they are. And conservatism, by definition, wants
to conserve that. So, yeah, I think your analysis
is good and I think there's even more to it.
Speaker 6: OK, thank you so much.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. Thank you
for the call. That's that's an
interesting topic. I like this one